foreign
[Music]
guys back once again with another tomes
of Terror book review
so not too long ago I feel like it's
probably like a few months ago
um I actually gave a quite glowing
review to the excellent 2020 Novella
which is called the rotting Within by
Matt Kurtz and if you haven't read that
like seriously you should read it I
think it's still on Kindle unlimited if
you have that and actually much to my
pleasant surprise Matt Kurtz himself
contacted me through email
and offered me a copy of his latest book
which is also a novella and he called it
like a Creature Feature type of thing
and it's called Shock waves and it was
actually just published by Umbra press
like just this year so I mean because I
said in my writing Within review that I
really was looking forward to reading
more of this guy's stuff
um you know obviously he offered it to
me so I was like oh well I was all too
happy to accept it so he sent me like an
ebook version of it and I noticed when I
was reading it that um my review of his
previous book The rotting within is
actually quoted at the beginning of this
new one like with a bunch of other ones
and that actually kind of made me I was
like wow I feel like a famous person
like whose opinions about books like
people care about I thought that was
kind of neat so it's like he didn't tell
me that like going in so I thought it
was like really funny it was like Hey I
said that so I thought that was kind of
cool
so uh so shock waves
uh this actually it's only the ebook
version is only about 166 pages I read
it probably in a couple of hours because
I read like fairly fast and because it's
so short it absolutely does not [__]
around I mean it pretty much Dives right
into the horror like in the first few
minutes and really doesn't let up until
the very very end so just like I
mentioned when I was talking about the
running within
um this Novella is really really tight
really Relentless there's like no
[__] there's no fluff there's no
anything like that
um the characters are introduced with
just enough like very economical detail
to get you emotionally invested in them
um all the better for you to be like
really devastated when they usually get
horribly killed not always but you know
you never know when it's gonna happen so
I'm just saying like you get really
attached to people and then you're like
oh [__] you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing so I'm gonna say like Matt
Curtis in that way is he's really kind
of like a Fearless writer but because he
doesn't really seem to shy away from
bumping off you know just beloved
characters cute babies you know [__]
like that he just like does not give one
single [__] and I kind of love that you
know so because you can never be
entirely sure like since he does that
you can never be entirely sure like even
if the main protagonists are even safe
so the stakes like seem like a lot
higher so shock waves is set in 1988 and
it's told from the first person
perspective of a 17 year old kid who you
find out eventually his name is Danny
and he works uh his summers at this
Texas this place in Texas called The
Lone Star Land amusement park
so interestingly in his endnotes Matt
Kurtz said that this story is somewhat
autobiographical I mean obviously like
if you've read it like it can't be
really autobiographical because of all
the crazy [__] that happens in it but uh
in the sense that he actually was a ride
Foreman at an amusement park like when
he was a teenager so since he had such
familiarity with like the procedures and
all of the stuff surrounding that job it
really does give the book like this real
immersive quality and you know a good
dose of realism because you know the
writer actually knew what he was talking
about and knew like what the procedures
were for working in that you know
context so yeah so we get introduced to
Danny and a couple of his other
co-workers like around the park um
including a girl named Kyra who is this
kind of like go-getter like a gymnast
like she does gymnastics on the side and
she kind of factors a lot larger into
the story later on but this particular
summer uh Danny's main preoccupation
is with uh his relationship with his
girlfriend of two years whose name is
Stacy now she also works at the park so
prior to the events of the novella like
as a matter of fact like right before
the events start like right before the
beginning
um Danny and Stacy had something of an
argument or disagreement I guess or
something like that like over there
break
and now that Danny is back at work like
Manning his station he's feeling pretty
bad about some stuff that he said and so
he's kind of like just counting the
hours until his shift ends so he can go
like apologize to her and like make
everything right now we don't actually
find out until later uh what the fight
was about but uh All I'm gonna say about
that is that it actually like raises the
stakes of the story like significantly
like when you find out what it is later
on
so Danny is acting as a ride Foreman
on a roller coaster which is called
Shock waves uh along with his like
another co-worker who's the assistant
Foreman whose name is Greg now the guys
are hoping that the park is gonna close
earlier than usual because there's this
huge thunderstorm coming in with like
all this lightning and stuff and
obviously when you have lightning and
stuff you can't have these rides like up
in the air because people get struck by
lightning so they usually will the
managers will usually close the park
down so they're kind of waiting for that
call to come but it hasn't come yet so
you know for now they just have to like
keep doing what they're doing because
you know there are still a few
straggling part guests and they're
climbing onto the coaster getting ready
to ride it and Danny has to you know
make sure that they're safe now on this
particular ride because a few guests
during like throughout the course of the
day had been complaining about one of
the turns like on the roller coaster
being way bumpier or like feeling way
sketchier than usual
um Danny decides that he's going to get
on the roller coaster himself like on
this ride like with the guests to kind
of check it out because he's like well I
know I'm supposed to call the park
mechanic who's this Surly big dude like
named Billy but he's like I don't really
like having to talk to that dude so I'm
just gonna check it out myself and then
if if I think something's wrong then
I'll call him like as a last resort
however uh you know so he gets on there
with the guests and everything like that
and no sooner though has the roller
coaster just crested that first hell
then literally like all hell begins to
break loose
so it so happens that right next to the
amusement park is this big construction
site now Danny doesn't actually have any
idea what the [__] they're building over
there I don't think you ever do find out
but crews are just hard at work like day
and night he's like holy crap whatever
that is they're like putting it up like
really fast so while Danny and a handful
of other people are on the roller
coaster this huge explosion like just
rocks the construction site next door
and it ends up opening up this like that
starts out as like a 10 foot wide Rift
like in the earth and kind of knocks out
all the power to the park and also kind
of knocks the roller coaster like
slightly off the tracks because it kind
of you know the Shockwave and everything
like that so see Shockwave it's it's a
double meaning
so obviously everybody in the park now
is like plunged Into Darkness and
they're stuck on this roller coaster
like way the [__] up in the air
so Danny because he's the Park employee
uh feels like he has to try and like
reassure everybody that oh you know
somebody will come along soon and like
help us off the ride
um you know and for a few minutes it
does actually seem like this is what's
gonna happen because there are protocols
in place to deal with this sort of event
like power outages and things like that
so it does seem like everything's kind
of going according to plan at least at
first but then everybody kind of glances
over toward the construction site and
begins to notice to their alarm that
there are
um things kind of coming out of this big
huge crack in the earth uh some of these
things have like our big bat like things
like with wings on them some of them are
like big like segmented insects
centipede type things kind of with
compound eyes and stuff some of them
have like tentacles and [__] like that
so essentially like Monsters is what I'm
saying like all these monsters are like
coming in this crack in the Earth
um you know and all of them they kind of
look like Monsters like insects or
spiders and things like that like on you
know our planet but um are way larger
than they have any way to be and also um
seem to have an appetite for flesh so
there's that so the rest of the story
basically is just this kind of real
nail-biting journey through this through
parts of this amusement park because
Danny and this little ragtag gang of
survivors they're trying to get down
from the roller coaster get um to the
next ride over which is like called Rip
Roaring Rapids or something like that um
to rescue Danny's girlfriend Stacy
because that's where she was working and
he actually doesn't know if she's alive
or not because he can't see her after
that they're kind of hoping to get the
[__] out of the park and into the
surrounding neighborhoods to um because
two of the people that are with them
like in the gang that were uh you know
guests at the park whose name is arwan
and Lydia they actually left their
little boy like with the grand mother
and she lives just like a few blocks
away from the park so they're hoping to
like kind of get to the end of the park
and like climb over the wall and like
get over there and make sure that
they're okay
so all along the way like all along this
journey that they're taking
um you know just Monsters of all
descriptions are just swooping in just
running at them like on land like flying
in from the air like coming out of the
water like some of the rides that are
like water and stuff like that and you
know we're just kind of like trying to
pick them off one by one you know tear
them in half or whatever so some of the
deaths here are gonna say are pretty
gnarly
um so you know if you're kind of like a
Gore Hound or whatever you should be I I
feel like you would be more than
satisfied like with the level of Carnage
and as I also mentioned in my previous
review that I did of his other book The
Writing within this is actually kind of
like the kind of story that constitutes
real horror like what I would consider
Real Horror because it just describes
like completely nice blameless people
just getting torn to pieces for no
reason really like they didn't deserve
it or anything like that it's just they
happen to be on a roller coaster at
amusement park when this crack and the
Earth opened and all these hungry
monsters came out and wanted to eat them
and you know it sucks to be them pretty
much so much like the roller coaster
that gives the book its name shock waves
uh this is actually much like a roller
coaster ride itself it's very very
thrilling it's very fast paced
um has a bunch of ups and downs and it
has much like his last book did a real
emotional heart at its core and I think
that largely that's because you're
seeing everything through the point of
view of Danny who's just this real
affable uh likable character and he's
also kind of he's an every man but he's
also very like humbly heroic I guess
like because he has to be he has to like
step up and you know he's trying to get
to his girlfriend and there's just no
damn way that he is gonna leave the park
without her so it's you know so it's
it's really kind of like a good he's
just a really really good character
because he's just a kid I mean he's only
17 but he really has to like kind of
drop his nuts and get in there and like
help everybody out and he's just like a
really really good um character
um so honestly I kind of think that Matt
Kurtz is quickly being becoming one of
my favorite horror writers I mean I've
only read two of his things like so far
but I mean both of the things have been
outstanding
um his stuff is just really fun it's
really gory it's really engaging like it
has like a real good heart to it you get
real emotionally invested in the
characters and I mean even though he's
not like Reinventing the wheel he's not
doing anything like really uh you know
Innovative or anything in that way you
know what I mean but he's just taking
everything that makes Geeks like me like
really really love horror and he's just
going balls to the wall with it and he's
just really concerned about you just
having like a really nasty good time you
know what I mean with this with this
book and not it doesn't have to be super
deep or anything like that it's just
[__] great and all his stuff is like
real cinematic as well so and I think I
said in my writing Within review that I
thought it'd make a great movie
um same thing here I think this would
make like a fantastic monster movie and
it would be so fun like seeing all the
monster designs because all the monsters
like look kind of different you know
what I mean so I think that would be
really and the gore would be off the
chain because like I said monsters
they're eating peoples they're just kind
of like tearing people in half and like
ripping Limbs and heads and [__] like
that off so it would be a lot of fun I I
feel like they made this into a movie I
was gonna say too that he also has a
real I mean he's his writing is really
really good I mean he has really good
like I said it's very economical it's
not real adorned or anything like that
but he's very good at like picking like
the exact right words like to get across
um you know what he wants to get across
and like so you can picture it in your
head he's also really good at doing real
brief but very targeted characterization
um that gets you on board with the
characters like pretty much immediately
and like I said he kind of does that
sometimes
um kind of in order to crush your spirit
when something terrible happens to this
person because man some terrible [__]
happens to like some nice people in this
so you know what I mean I'm just saying
uh but yeah so if you haven't read any
of Matt Curts and stuff I would
definitely recommend it this is his
newest one like I said it just came out
this year and this is some good [__] man
um if you're just really into balls to
the wall gory just fun horror that's not
it's not super complicated or anything
like it's just a very simple Siege type
story it's just you know a group of
survivors trying to get through this
amusement park without getting eaten by
monsters essentially that's the entire
that's the entire story but it's just
executed so so well and I really really
had a great time with it so like I said
I'm very excited to read more of Matt
Curt's stuff because he's written a
couple more novels and some uh short
story collections as well which actually
I kind of want to dig into because I
really like short stories but yeah if
you haven't read it like seriously
um read some of his stuff I believe this
one is also on Kindle unlimited if you
have a um subscription to that like you
can read the ebook for free so yeah I
would definitely recommend it if you're
into that kind of thing so that will do
it for this tomes of Terror and I'll see
you again on the next one bye